BRIAN: REPUBLICANS IN NEW YORK
ARE IN A BATTLE TO TAKE CONTROL.
THEY JUST ADDED A NUMBER OF
REPUBLICAN HOUSE MEMBERS, TOO.
YOU HAVE LEE ZELDIN AND MIKE
WALLACE IN TIGHT RACES.
ZELLE IS UP ON KATHY HOCHUL.
THEY ARE REALLY COMPETITIVE THIS
YEAR.
WHAT IS IT ABOUT?
THE REPUBLICANS IN NEW YORK, ARE
THEY CABLE TO KICK OFF THE REST
PRIOR?
SID ROSENBERG IS HERE, AND HIS
NEW BOOK "CITIZENS UNITED" IS
OUT.
>> I LOVE THE KING OF NEW YORK.
I'M GOING TO STEAL THAT.
FIRST OFF, NEW YORK READY TO
FLIP PEOPLE ON THE OUTSIDE.
BUT NEW YORK HAS ALWAYS BEEN SO
LIBERAL.
>> ZELDIN HAS A SHOT.
PEOPLE ARE SICK AND TIRED OF THE
CRIME WHICH IS SKYROCKETING ARE
EVERY DAY.
21% AGGRAVATED ASSAULTS ARE UP.
THEY ARE SICK OF SEEING THE
HOMELESS ON THE STREETS.
THE FILTH, THE TAXES.
BOTH REPUBLICANS AND DEMOCRATS
WANT SAFETY AND CLEAN STREETS.
I THINK ZELDIN WILL MAKE IT A
CLOSE RACE.
KATHY HOCHUL WON'T DEBATE.
BRIAN: SHE WON'T COMMIT.
IF SHE WAITS, IT'S HARD TO SEE
HER NUMBERS GROWING.
WHAT'S HAPPENED NOW IS LOCAL
POLITICS EQUAL NATIONAL
POLITICS.
THE SAME THINGS WE ARE TALKING
ABOUT ON A NATIONAL LEVEL, THE
BORDER, CRIME, SAFETY, TAXES,
THAT'S WHAT WE TALK ABOUT
LOCALLY.
THAT GIVES MIKE WALL A SHOT.
RIGHT NOW HE'S BEATING MALONEY
BY 2 POINTS IN THE LATEST POLL.
BRIAN: MAYOR ADAMS AT FIRST WAS
VERY ANGRY.
I THINK NOW HE'S ON HIS HEELS A
BIT.
HE SAID WE ARE WRITING CHECKS IN
NEW YORK CITY TO SET UP AN
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANT CENTER.
HERE IS MAYOR ADAMS TALKING
THURSDAY ABOUT THE ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION POLICY OF THE
ADMINISTRATION.
>> ANYONE WHO STATES THAT THIS
ADMINISTRATION DOES NOT HAVE A
HANDLE ON THIS CRISIS MUST HAVE
BEEN SLEEPING UNDER A ROCK.
THE REPUBLICAN PARTY, THEY
CREATED A BLUEPRINT THAT'S
INHUMANE, FOR THE GOVERNOR TO
SEND IMMIGRANTS TO MARTHA'S
VINEYARD WITHOUT ANY
COORDINATION, WHICH IS CREATING
REAL CRISES.
BRIAN: ARE THEY WEARING MASKS TO
STOP FROM LAUGHING?
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN?
>> I COVERED ADAMS.
AND AT THIS POINT HE'S STARTING
TO MAKE BILL DEBLASIO LOOK LIKE
EINSTEIN.
HE CAN'T EXPLAIN HIMSELF VERY
WELL.
AN ILLEGAL MIGRANT, NOT SUCH A
HORRIBLE THING.
IT COULD BE A LOT WORSE.
GOVERNOR ABBOTT AND GOVERNOR
DeSANTIS ARE TWO AMERICAN
HEROES.
IN MY BOOK THEY ARE WHAT THIS
COUNTRY IS ALL ABOUT, NOT ERIC
ADAMS.
BRIAN: HE TOOK MIGRANTS IN
FLORIDA AND SENT THEM TO
MARTHA'S VINEYARD AND ABBOTT
SENT THEM TO THE VICE
PRESIDENT'S HOUSE.
>> ALL THESE ELASTIC PANTS
GOVERNORS ARE PULLING THEIR OWN
STUNTS.
RON DeSANTIS IS THAT GUY YOU
WENT TO HIGH SCHOOL WITH WHO
WANTED TO BE PROM KING BUT
INSTEAD HE PULLED THE FIRE ALARM
AND RUINED IT FOR EVERYBODY.
>> 8,000 MIGRANTS ARE COMING
THROUGH A DAY.
>> JIMMY KIMMEL SHOULD BE
WORRIED ABOUT HIS OWN SHOW.
ALL THEY ARE DOING IS SPOUTING
OUT, REGURGITATING DEMOCRAT
POLICY.
TEXAS GETS 8,000 A DAY.
WE GET 80.
THEY HAVE GOT TO STOP.
THEY ARE GIVING MEES THESE
PEOPLE DINNERS AND TICKETS AND
FANCY HOTEL ROOMS.
I SHOULD BE TREATED THAT WELL.
BRIAN: HOW IMPORTANT IS AARON
JUDGE'S RUN FOR THE SINGLE
SEASON HOME RUN RECORD?
HE'S IN THE HIGH 50s ALREADY.
WHAT'S YOUR TAKE ON WHAT THIS
MEANS?
>> HE'S GOING TO BREAK THAT
RECORD SOMETIME NEXT WEEK.
BRIAN: I THINK HE HAS PITTSBURGH
AFTER THAT.
>> HE DOES.
HE'S A GOOD GUY WITH NO STEROID
CONTROVERSIES.
YOU KNOW, BRIAN, A ROD, EVERY
HOME RUN HITTER HAD THAT STEROID
AROUND THEM.
NOT AARON JUDGE.
BRIAN: 30 HOME RUNS, HE HAS A
SHOT AT THE TRIPLE CROWN.
YOU TALK ABOUT SPORTS AND YOU
HAVE ANECDOTES.
>> WHEN I WAS A LITTLE KID I WON
A CONTEST IN NEW YORK CITY TO BE
THE MASCOT OF THE WEEK FOR THE
JETS.
IT WOULD ALLOW ME TO SIT ON A
BENCH WITH JOE NAMATH.
AND THE JETS DECIDED THAT LITTLE
SYDNEY ROSENBERG FROM BROOKLYN
WOULD BE A DISTRACTION.
INSTEAD THEY CALLED MY FATHER
AND SENT ME A SIGNED FOOTBALL.
AND I BECAME THE BIG JEST GIANTS
FAN EVER.
BRIAN: CONGRATULATIONS ON THE
BO